what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time while wall
street's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right i'm here with 101
dalmatians paulina
pompliano don't forget that lunch money
is now sponsored by block five block
five has three products one you can go
buy and sell crypto on their crypto
exchange
two you give them crypto they give you a
us dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral
or three you can earn up to 8.6 percent
apy in an interest-bearing account
go get a blockfy account blackfy.com go
get a block by account blockfly.com
pomp let's go somebody is loud today bam
i got that trillionaire energy today
let's go
i got the quadrillionaire energy today
not obviously not and or
quadrillionaires are not happy but go
ahead i'm very happy
let's go you see how he got scared yeah
i ain't [ __ ] with her the coronavirus
crisis pushed global debt levels to a
new high of
over 272 trillion dollars talk about
trillionaire energy
in the third quarter um the institute
for international finance
warned of the attack of the debt tsunami
272 trillion dollars in global debt who
the hell we owe
the debt to the aliens who do we owe the
debt to
you saw that in a meme of course who
do we owe the debt to they're crazy
they can give it to me it's just we just
owe debt to each other
this is literally like a house of cards
you ever stack the cards up try to build
a house when you're younger and the wind
blows and it all falls apart so who so
where
who's paying this debt they don't know
nobody knows where the debt is
nobody knows who's gonna pay the debt
it's because it's all
a facade they have imaginary
money that they're just printing more
and more and more and more and more of
but if you could just edit your bank
account why do you need my tax dollars
if you can edit your bank account why do
we have to have debt
you can just create money that's all i
gotta say 272 trillion dollars of global
yelling
it makes no sense jpmorgan chase ceo
jamie dimon said blockchain will have a
pivotal role in the future of finance
even if bitcoin is not his cup of tea
cup of tea
cup of tea do you want me to comment on
this
well what i think is happening here as a
bitcoin analyst
macro commentator is that i believe
jamie demon
does not know what he is talking about
facts
nobody cares what jamie dimon says
bitcoin definitely doesn't care what
jamie dimon but does it doesn't jp
morgan like actually have
patents and blockchain technology and
stuff of course
jamie dimon said he'd fire anyone if
they bought bitcoin or retreating
bitcoin stupid enough yeah to buy
remember that
i bet you that jamie dimon has
a bunch of jp morgan clients that
they've been putting in bitcoin
we're telling them to go get big so i'm
reading this article on coindesk and
they have this uh
chart that says would you rather have
jamie diamond's cup of tea or bitcoin in
2020
and bitcoin's like whoosh 145
jp morgan's down 14 this year and
bitcoin's up 145
well which cup of tea would you like all
right
and by the way what i've been telling
you guys long bitcoin short the bankers
tesla is getting added to the s p 500
um on december i think 20 something 21st
um for the first time in its 17-year
history tesla has posted
four straight profitable quarters in a
row
elon is popping you want to do your
dance no
just don't bet against innovators are
you all crazy
yeah this was the easiest call of all
time what are y'all doing
trying to short innovation
when you see innovation happening
there's only one thing to do
get out of the way because innovation
ain't slowing down for nobody
he's built the best electric vehicle the
car
company is going to end up being the
most valuable companies in the world
he is innovating get out of the way
don't stand there and say i'm going to
short you you're going to fail
sure sometimes innovators fail but when
they're right
and sometimes they're delusional but go
on when they're right
they're really really really right and
that's what we're seeing here
the man literally helped create reusable
rockets that land
on a drone ship in the ocean he created
the best electric vehicle
he's going to end up drastically
accelerating the adoption
of renewable energy and we have a friend
who called me drunk a couple of weekends
ago and all he wanted to tell me was
he was putting all his money in tesla
because tesla's gonna go to saturn
and we had to explain to him i think
you're confused i think you're talking
about spacex
and mars that's a whole nother situation
you know who you are if you're watching
okay long elon all right
so you know dolly parton yes country
music super
she's a very nice person she's an
awesome person and
she made a million dollar donation um to
coronavirus vaccine research
which supported the development of the
moderna vaccine so dolly parton's taking
credit for having developed
a credit card she just donated a million
dollars to
corona vaccine research i think that's
great ah
see um she donated the million dollars
after her friend dr
naji abumrad of the vanderbilt institute
for infection
immunology and inflammation told her
that he needed some help well look i i
think that what's interesting about this
is uh there's a lot of people who
stepped up government stepped up
individuals stepped up right really
really trying to help get this vaccine
uh but we still don't have it i know but
i just think it's cool that private
figures like dolly parton are putting
more money
towards research that's awesome there's
also a ton of people who donated money
for ppe
right like all of the uh masks and
gloves and all that when that was like a
really big problem
like that that's the stuff it's just
people helping people that's what we
need
we don't need the government telling us
to sit in our houses
cuomo okay
anthony's mad because he can't attend
school right now
he's a fool are we talking are we
talking about that subject no okay well
i'm gonna talk about that subject real
quick
this idiot this idiot
has been wrong so many times i've lost
count but yet
he wrote a book think about this the
governor of new york
wrote a book about how he had great
leadership
conquering the coronavirus and now
after he wrote the book the coronavirus
had the schools get close and they're
talking about another lockdown
how arrogant and stupid do you have to
be to have written a book and recorded
the audio version yourself
as the governor during a coronavirus at
the same time that you're telling your
small business owners that they can't
operate their businesses they're all
shutting down
and then you get a 25 000 bonus
you should give up your entire salary
not get a bonus
for your boneheaded mistakes and then to
cap it all off
everyone forgets there's
one major idiot in the world who ordered
elderly covid patients back into the
elderly care homes
and ended up killing thousands of people
he's the governor of new york and he
wrote a book about how great he did for
the
coronavirus but he sent people that were
coveted patients
back into the elderly homes and then it
ran rampant through the elderly homes
it's disgusting we shouldn't accept it
we should literally vote all the fools
out of office
that's it sorry i had to get that off my
chest i saw a tweet yesterday
that she showed me that literally
somebody was like so can we take our
kids to school
at the restaurant the schools are closed
but the restaurants the gyms the massage
parlors the nail salons
those are all like what the city's
priorities are and
i think schools and kids education
should be at the top of the priority
especially since they have shown that
covet is not being transmitted and
whatever in school so why are we
anyway whatever facts um okay we should
get you on a rant
all right go ahead next also cuomo don't
yell at journalists like that
um for the first time in 55 years cash
will not be accepted at the super bowl
the national football league will make
its championship game
all digital with the backing of its
corporate client
partner visa it's going to be in tampa
bay it will use only contactless
payment methods of the game in the
league's fan experience
that's kind of nice i i hate cash it's
so dirty
i mean look i i feel like uh yes this is
good
but uh it also does hurt some people
um who don't have you know other things
that you they are cap
mainly cash based but i don't know if
you're going to the super right that's
what i was going to say
you only operate in cash but but i think
it is interesting that we're moving
more and more into this cashless world
right oh it's definitely yeah
that's the end goal here for sure cool
all right next
all right so we're do it's ask lunch
money time
is this your favorite part of this yes i
love this part all right all right
selena i'm only doing this because it
makes her happy
you love this part he loves this right
he told me in private
he said he said it's my favorite part
it's it's so
my favorite that like i don't even want
to do the rest of the laundry
i just look how bad of a liar she is
she's such a bad lie okay
salil vanvari said both of you have
multiple vibrant oh i like that word
vibrant forms of communities on the
internet how did you both start your
journeys to create these communities and
why have you chosen to diversify across
platforms
and types of content rather than to
double down on the most
lucrative platform in audience go ahead
um so for me community
for the profile i haven't done any
proper advertising
or what is it promotion or marketing or
whatever
of the profile it's all been through
social media and word of mouth
and i find that that is the best type of
community because it brings in such
like-minded people and people who are
genuinely interested in the content
um this week i've been doing a virtual
meetup
all across the world in 14 cities across
the world
to meet people and um that's how you
build community
what did you say hand-to-hand combat
except not combat more of like
meeting nicely true facts
what about you i just say what i say and
people show up
i've done nothing in terms of like tried
to build community and it's if i
literally
when people got questions i answer them
people want to talk i talk when people
want to hear what i got to say i say
things but
it's uh mine has been much less
intentional
and is a credit to my intelligent wife
here who is
way smarter than me but uh yeah i don't
know i just found all the psychos on the
internet
welcome kyle stark great answers to the
questions as well as on
debt military and writing tips i am 29
and i have recently started an online
business alongside a full-time job
i've considered joining the canadian
military and just recently applied
pomp in your opinion am i too late to
join should i focus on the business
instead
yeah these questions are always a little
bit difficult because i don't have all
the
um kind of context but two things that
are important i think
one is uh i would ask myself what am i
trying to get out of joining the
military
uh at the age of 29 um
you know one consideration is definitely
can your body withstand it like i'm 32
uh you know i'm a savage like you don't
get a twist like i am a savage and i
will do what i got to do
but you know it was easier to do when i
was 18 19 20 21 years old then at 32
you know i could basically not sleep and
go out and do all kinds of crazy
physical stuff
at 29 30 31 like it's a little bit
harder obviously into your 40s would be
even more difficult
so that's one it's just like can your
body handle it two is what are you
trying to get out of it um is it
hey i think i have to go to the military
to get a job i want to get leadership
training i want to do something else
um you know it's usually not a decision
that you can reverse
so when you decide then you're going to
go and you're going to be there for a
couple of years
so that's important uh and then the
other thing is in terms of like business
uh my advice always around how do you
get
the most experience with businesses do
business right if you said to somebody
hey how do you get better at basketball
like go play basketball
right you wanna get better at business
like go do business right and whether
that's you start your business
you go and you help somebody else build
their business like just put the reps in
and that's how you're going to get
better at it so
it's hard for me to kind of give a a
finite answer but i think that's the
kind of the framework i would use to
think about it what am i trying to
accomplish is the military the only way
to do it or is it the best way to do it
and then if i want to actually optimize
for business then the best thing i can
do is just go do business
cool federico hi guys i'm a 25 year old
italian guy free italian banksy
watch yesterday's lunch money for that
reference what would you see
as business opportunities that have had
success in the us but have not yet
reached the european market
and what advice would you give someone
my age for starting a business
i don't know if there's business
opportunities that are u.s only or u.s
exclusive that are eventually going to
go to europe the way that i wouldn't
focus so much on like hey how do i
replicate a us-based business
i think my better advice is like
find a problem in your life like there
is something that is a problem in your
life and what you should ask yourself is
would people be willing to pay or would
people be happy if i solved that problem
uh how many other people have this
problem and so one of the problems that
i see with a lot of young founders is
they basically look and they say well
what is working for somebody else they
built like a me too business right like
oh she has a business selling
uh i don't know cups oh i me too i want
to sell cups well like yeah sure
but that actually might not be the best
thing and so if you want more
information on this peter thiel has a
great talk
on youtube um that he i think it's
called competition is for losers
um and it's all about like you actually
want to build a monopoly
right and people kind of get scared when
the hero i thought monopolies were bad
like no it's just you want to build a
monopoly and that monopoly ends up being
you want to be the best at doing
something you want to solve a problem so
well that you're the only person who can
do that
um and so i think that if you're going
to start a business again what are you
optimizing for you want just extra cash
cool you can go do what everyone else is
doing you can literally go sell baseball
cards on the street corner you want to
build a really
big big business that ends up being a
category defining business you got to do
something that no one else is doing got
to create the category right so it's
what are you optimizing for and then be
intelligent about how big is the market
i'm going after what's the likely
outcome here
how much money can this actually make
for a business or for myself and does
that fit what i'm trying to accomplish
yeah all right let's go last question
we're late
eric pomp if you had to start all over
today with nothing more than you and
paulina what steps would you take to
rebuild your wealth
he'd count on me to rebuild the wealth i
told polina this one time if i lost
everything right now
i'd make more money in my lifetime than
if i keep going
he did tell me that one time yeah for
sure 100
because i would basically be forced to
take bigger swings um
which uh ultimately would end up better
and i have all the knowledge like
people always forget like the number one
valuable thing that i have is i have the
information in my head not with
everybody like
everybody even if you lose everything
you still have your brain
yeah you you could absolutely take me to
a country i have no doubt you could take
me to a country you could drop me off
give me six months and i'll have built a
multi-million dollar business
facts now what is it going to be but the
question is
how that's exactly what i already said
uh
what i would do is i would look at three
things i would look at what are the
skills i have
right what are the problems that need to
be solved and three what am i
uniquely where do i have an advantage in
applying those skills to that problem
and so in the united states you know
there's really really easy ideas around
like
everything from content to selling
physical products to building software
whatever
when you go to other countries a lot of
times what ends up happening is like you
don't necessarily need to recreate the
wheel to like build a business that does
let's say a million dollars a year in
revenue
there's pizza places that do that right
imagine if somebody started a pizza shop
and then the next person was like oh
somebody already did that like no they
just went down the street and they're
like oh this one's closer to more people
like
i'll just build one down there and the
restaurants may do
250 500 a million dollars in revenue a
year
but what ends up happening is like they
figured out an advantage whether it was
hey my food tastes better it's better
priced i have delivery my competitors
don't it's in a better location like
whatever
so you don't have to necessarily come up
with an idea that no one's ever thought
of before
what you've got to be able to do is you
got to be able to uh
apply in a specific way and then you've
got to be intelligent about
what am i trying to do right watch this
how much monthly revenue do you need to
get to a billion dollars a year
a million 83 333 or something
facts you know why she knows that
because everybody i talk to all the time
that's why i say to them what is your
plan to get to 83
333 a month i think that's right
what is your plan and if you can't
answer that question you'll never get to
a million dollars a year in revenue
because you don't have a plan to get to
eighty three thousand three hundred
thirty three dollars a month
but that's it like if you break it down
that's what you have to get to you have
to build a business you want a million
dollar a year business you gotta build
83 33 a month when you start to think of
that you get okay well if i divide that
by four what is that
oh that's about uh 21 000 a month a week
right by day right you just keep
breaking it down breaking down breaking
it down it would be three dollars short
my
right but like that's the whole point is
you you kind of continuously go through
the exercise
of what do i have to do and break down
the big problem into smaller pieces and
then just attack this and a lot of times
you find out that it's not necessarily
in my case creating more content or
creating more products or whatever it
may be
it's just changing your strategy and
doing something different with the
existing stuff you have
i might do that i might go somewhere for
30 days and see what i could do
that'd be why go to bulgaria if i went
to bulgaria i'd be a
gazillion oh i don't know the bulgarians
love me
i don't know you get every woman in the
country i would just hit them with tcm
noble cressiva now give me your money
and they would give me all their money
that means uh that means you look
beautiful all right that's it for today
ciao bang bang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money as much as
we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor a user
and a huge fan what
you're a bigger fan of block five than
you are of me block flies my second
favorite thing in the world behind
polina
they've got three products they can give
you a us dollar loan
you can earn up to eight point percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends